in just a few hours president Trump will
unveil his strategy for dealing with
Iran in a White House address the
president is expected to decertify that
Iran is complying with the landmark
nuclear agreement but stopped short of
tearing it up instead he's expected to
give Congress the power to reimpose
sanctions against Iran Elizabeth Palmer
is standing by with reaction in Tehran
but first we go to Margaret Brennan at
the White House Margaret good morning
good morning president Trump will
sanction Iran's Revolutionary Guard and
then he will say the nuclear deal is no
longer in America's best interests his
national security advisors have
scrambled to stop him from tearing up
that deal and today he'll ask Congress
and the Secretary of State to fix it
it's a high-stakes gamble and it's aimed
at unraveling President Obama's
signature foreign policy achievement
clearly the president has he's deep in
thought to say the least about way ahead
in Iran chief of staff John Kelly said
Thursday that US forces are poised to
rein in Iran's destabilizing behavior in
the Middle East we have footprints on
the ground naval and air forces there to
just demonstrate our resolve our
friendship today President Trump will
announce how he'll push back on Iran's
ballistic missile test and support for
terror organizations like Hezbollah the
Iranian regime supports terrorism and
exports violence but Trump
administration sources tell CBS News
that the president will not deliver on
his campaign promise to tear up the
Obama era deal to freeze Iran's nuclear
program why on earth would anybody have
signed a deal like that US intelligence
confirms that Iran has abided by the
terms of the agreement but today the
president will refuse to certify its
compliance instead he'll punt to
Congress and allow it to decide within
60 days whether to reimpose sanctions on
Iran that puts a lot of power in the
hands of senators Tom cotton and bob
corker who are setting new goal posts
for Iran they're proposing a new law
that puts indefinite restrictions on
Iran's nuclear program bolsters
inspections and snaps back sanctions
if Iran comes within a one-year breakout
period of making a nuclear weapon
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson will
now try to negotiate a second nuclear
agreement to add on to the Obama era one
but neither Iran or any of America's
five partner countries have agreed to
that and they privately accused
President Trump of unraveling something
that endangers national security purely
for political gain beyond oh yeah Europe
Russia and China monitor monitoring
things closely Margaret thank you